next question is about Andrew yang hey
David
when will Andrew yang enter the top
three Democratic primary candidates in
the polling so I'm going to assume that
this is a serious question because the
person who sent it has been emailing me
about Andrew yang in a perfectly
reasonable and serious manner for a year
and they genuinely seem to be fans and
supporters of Andrew yang I'm not going
to assume it's a trolling question but
here's the deal
Andrew yang is not going to enter the
top three in 2020 democratic polling and
that's okay
all right he's done way more than many
people expected he has introduced some
interesting ideas into the 2020
Democratic primary discussion now I know
a lot of people will say David stop it
andrew has said his goal is not poll
three percent his goal is to be
President of the United States that's
great that should be everyone's goal
who's running for president I wish
everybody was genuinely running because
they believe that they are going to be
President of the United States I have no
problem with Andrew yang personally I
like him I've interviewed him multiple
times I see him as sincere I see him as
genuine I don't see him as some kind of
right libertarian Trojan horse as some
people have pointed out he has policy
ideas some are better than others there
are problems with some of his policy
ideas and that's all as we would expect
with any candidate but he's not going to
poll in the top three and it's not
because I don't believe in him okay
Andrew yang was in sixth place heading
into the third debate last night behind
Biden Bernie Warren Harris and Budaj
edge it is already a huge accomplishment
that he's ahead of all sorts of actual
elected officials and political insiders
he's ahead of Beto and Cory Booker and
Tulsi Gabbard and numerous other members
of Congress and more establishment
people who had higher name recognition
at the beginning of this campaign now
maybe I'll be eating my hat next week if
new post-debate polling shows Andrew
yang in third place but between Biden
and Bernie and Warren
that's roughly 2/3 of the Democratic
primary electorate already if you look
at their second choices I don't see a
mathematical path
for Andrew yang to break the top-three
even if everyone other than Biden Burnie
and Warren drops out and Andrew yang
gets a full 50% of all of that support
of all those other people that's 11
points it's still not enough to break
into third place and that's not even
accounting for the reality that the
support of some of those other
candidates would go to Burnie Biden and
Warren making it even more difficult for
Andrew yang to catch up so he's not
going to enter the top three in this
election that doesn't mean he can't have
an impact it doesn't mean he's a bad
person it doesn't mean he's running a
bad campaign he has ideas some of which
are good and some of which are less good
like any candidate and that's all great
but if people are genuinely waiting for
the day in which we say Andrew Yang has
pulled into second place I don't see it
happening if you disagree with me give
me the mathematical path that Andrew
yang has not just he's gonna just crush
it off between now and Election Day in
the first primaries and he'll be in
second or third place before you know it
I just don't see it
convince me that I'm wrong